except could you plan on getting a mess
across the street walk through there and
walk up this square screen God stops us
acids or IDs then we're screwed
you and Nico and myself will walk
together we're going to get there first
everyone well squawks is the goofy group
of costume people don't put on your
Waldo gear until range we're Yap chewing
gum with an excuse okay let's talk then
I want to ask you a quick bit of advice
as we go in like it was a good excuse me
do you want to drive the viewers eye I
just need to stop all the way around
catch you hi I'm really still sleepy yes
Milan our game was up although I just
feel like getting credit which wants it
let's do it again I was in sooner mm-hmm
so I'm rolling into campus we were
worried that security guards to stop us
we're trying to go with excuses for
example we're on our way to the school
of cinema arts do a presentation on
360-degree videos and Sam actually
looked up a class but we didn't get
[ __ ] at all in fact we just ended up
disturbing a lot of students routines on
their way to class by stopping them and
asking them like Where's Waldo
she begins
breaking along you know I'm not aware of
any laws that we're breaking get film
here
a session that ran out of battery
all right so we just finished our day of
shooting out in Santa Monica we're just
gonna roll home with the top down
after all this troubleshooting the
solid-state drives have a little fun
little sticker on the back that's a
refurbished I've always had a high
failure rate with anything refurbished
eight over 528 Chronos is still dead
pretty accurate